[Music]
thank you
Gmail's popularity is falling off a
cliff in September of 2021 they
controlled a 35.25 of the market but by
October of 2022 they only controlled the
27.95 of the market this means that
Within These 13 months Gmail's market
share fell by a whopping 7.3 percent
this might not seem like a large amount
at first glance but it is when you
consider that basically everyone with an
internet connection uses email there's
estimated to be about 4.26 billion email
users worldwide so this means that Gmail
either lost 306 million users or the
people who are opening new email
accounts are choosing the other email
clients by far and it's probably some
sort of combination of both but why ever
since Gmail launched the consensus has
been that Gmail is the go to email
client whether we're talking about
personal use business use or fake email
use Gmail has been the bomb I would even
argue that some of the other email
clients have a negative stigma
surrounding them especially Yahoo and
Hotmail so how did Gmail go from being
the go to email service to losing a
fifth of their market share within a
year
to understand why Gmail is losing so
much market share we'll first have to
understand why they were so popular in
the first place and for this we'll have
to go back to April 4th day of 2004. if
you didn't know it Gmail was actually
launched as kind of a joke in fact
Sundar piche the current CEO of Google
was interviewing with the Google at the
time and when interviewers asked them
about his thoughts on Gmail even he
thought that it was just an April Fool's
Day joke the main reason that this
theory was so popular was because
Gmail's offering was simply a laughably
absurd at the time Yahoo and Hotmail
offered 2 megabytes of storage and 5
megabytes of storage respectively so
when Google came out with one gigabyte
of storage on April Fool's Day people
assumed that it was surely a joke but
April Fool's Day came and left and the
Gmail was still operational this
definitely caught people by surprise but
Google was just getting started in 2005
they would increase the storage to 2
gigabyte and in 2007 they would increase
the storage to 4 gigabytes very quickly
Gmail went from being a joke to being
the most desirable email client I don't
think I have to tell you the horrors of
trying to ensure that your entire email
archive is less than two or five
megabytes but storage was just the first
of many advantages for Gmail Gmail also
boasted the best spam filters the best
UI convenient grouping and ended the
ability to actually search through your
email and yes the other popular Services
didn't even let you search but while
everyone wanted Gmail not very many
people could actually get it and that
this brings us to the second appeal of
gmail which was scarcity here's the
thing offering these crazy storage
spaces that were magnitudes above the
competition turned out to be extremely
hard so they had to heavily limit the
number of users that use the service for
most companies this would have been a
major scaling bottleneck but Google
actually made it into an advantage by
making Gmail not invite only people
could only open a Gmail account if they
were invited by someone who already had
a Gmail account so if you had a Gmail
account you were very much the cool kid
in the friend group it wasn't until
nearly three years after the initial
launch that Google made Gmail available
to everyone by this point most people
who didn't yet have a Gmail account were
dying to switch so Gmail's market share
continued skyrocketing it wasn't just
everyday people who craved Gmail either
Google was very much getting schools and
institutions on board as well once again
thanks to their features for
institutions Google offered custom
domain names zero schedule downtime for
maintenance 30 gigabytes of storage up
to unlimited storage based on your
planet and the 24 7 phone and email
support once again Google blew the
competition out of the water so
switching was a no-brainer but this was
basically the end of the era of a
voluntary Gmail adoption while Gmail was
indeed at a superior Choice much of the
adoption that followed in the 2010s was
for forced adoption
for people who had already bought into
the Google ecosystem Google strategies
throughout the 2010s probably seemed
completely harmless but for the people
who didn't bind to the ecosystem well it
was definitely a pain in the neck what
Google started doing was merging all of
their platforms and requiring that you
have a single Google account for all of
them this probably doesn't seem like a
big deal today but back in the day
people got pretty heated about this and
likely the biggest culprit was Google
Plus if you're not familiar with Google
plus I don't blame you because it ended
up being a massive failure Google Plus
was basically Google's attempt at
growing their own social media platform
and competing against Facebook and it
seems harmless at a first glance but the
problem was that instead of enticing
people to join Google Plus because of
its features Google forced Google Plus
down people's throats for example in
2011 Google modified the Gmail account
creation process such that you had to
create a Google Plus profile and it this
was the case up until 2014 I think you
can see why this would be annoying but
this wasn't even close to being the
worst infraction likely the worst
infraction was their policy regarding
YouTube comments in 2013 YouTube
mandated that people must have Google
Plus accounts if they wanted to leave
comments for obvious reasons people were
enraged and even YouTube's co-founder
jaywood Korean would call out Google
Kareem would post quote why the F do I
need a Google Plus account to comment on
a video despite all the backlash Google
would not untie YouTube and Google Plus
up until 2015 while Google Plus was no
doubted the worst offender the same
fundamental argument was applicable to
Gmail accounts as well Google made it so
that you needed a Gmail account if you
wanted to do anything else on Google do
you want to use Google Drive well you're
gonna need a Gmail do you want a YouTube
account well you're gonna need a Gmail
do you want to download apps from the
Play Store well we're gonna need a Gmail
the most surprising part was that this
amount properly extended outside of
Google services as well I'm sure you're
all familiar with the login with the
Google feature while this feature is no
doubt super convenient and just further
strength in the Google Monopoly and
forced more people to get gmails even if
their use case had nothing to do with
using Gmail for email
a similar case could be made for the
education side of Gmail as well if
universities wanted to use Google
classroom or rollout school by Google
Calendars they needed a Google account
and they needed all of their students to
have Google accounts as well now
technically many Google features are
available without having an account but
we all know that these services are way
better if you have an account trying to
use Google services without an account
is like trying to use airpods with a
Windows computer it works but it's not
all that great
foreign
all of this brings us to where we are
today Google has become one of the most
dominant email clients in the world by
leveraging Futures scarcity and forced
adoption but their dominance is slowly
starting to fade away so what's
happening well the answer is pretty
simple Google is running out of trump
cards let's start with the features one
of Gmail's original selling features was
their massive storage but the
competition has not only cut up they've
actually overtaken Google take outlook
for example Outlook offers 15 gigabytes
of storage just for your email alone and
you get an additional 5 gigabytes
through OneDrive so Gmail is by no means
leaked ahead of the competition anymore
moving on to Gmail's second selling
factor of scarcity well no one really
thinks that having a Google account is
cool anymore and it's basically just the
norm and everyone already has one this
also makes it extremely difficult for
Google to force more adoption because
there's really no one left to convince
something else that we should mention it
is is that Google was never really the
ideal choice for students or
professionals because you can't leverage
Microsoft Office as much the reason that
many schools and universities Embrace
Google Docs slides and sheets is because
they made a collaboration extremely
convenient but if you put the
convenience and collaboration aspects
aside there's no question that Microsoft
Office is the Superior Service and over
the past 10 years Microsoft has very
much made strides with their own online
Office Products and collaboration
features Microsoft Office online is
actually free but that doesn't even
matter to institutions because they
usually already have a bunch of Office
365 subscriptions anyway so many
institutions are switching to Outlook to
create synergies between email cloud
storage and Microsoft Office we should
also mention that while schools and
universities very much Embrace Google
companies never did in fact nearly 196
000 companies in the US use Outlook
while only 4400 use Gmail another
Catalyst has stolen market share away
from Gmail is Apple's recent mail
privacy Protection Program this program
makes it harder for email marketers to
track down your IP address and your mail
activity and in an age where everyone is
worried about juggernauts like Google
and a Facebook collecting your data it's
not surprising that people are taking
every chance to protect themselves this
is made even easier by the fact that you
don't have to do anything to take
advantage of this program in fact it
would be easier to take advantage of
this program and then not take advantage
of it all you have to do is use the
inbuilt mail app on iPhones instead of
downloading the Gmail app and while
people have been wary of the iPhone
email app for years it seems like this
new feature is very much pushing people
towards it and we can see this in the
market share data in September of 2021
Apple had 50 market share but today they
have nearly 60 market share and I
suspect that this will only grow with
the time as people become more aware of
the importance of data protection
at the end of the day Gmail is by no
means dying or becoming irrelevant you
very much still need a Gmail account to
surf the Internet freely but it does
seem like people are using other
services for email more and more
frequently some of the service level
reasons for this are that Computing
email clients have caught up in terms of
features they have better integration
with Microsoft Office and the Google has
basically reached Market saturation but
if we look beyond that it appears that
we're seeing a larger Trend towards
privacy people are more aware than ever
how these companies are able to offer
their services for free and how they
really make money I mean here's all the
data that Google is able to collect just
off of Gmail it appears that Apple has
caught onto this consumer awareness and
that they're very much framing their
business with this in mind they're
positioning themselves as the big tech
company that doesn't collect data this
can be seen with their ask not to track
feature and their male privacy
Protection Program
and it's not just Apple who's jumping
onto this trend either in the messaging
space we have signal and in the social
media space we have it be real while
these services offer completely
different functionality their core
appeala is identical erasing the bad
aspects of big Tech and given that
Google already doesn't have that much
room to grow I suspect that Gmail's
popularity will simply continue to Trend
downwards but that's just what I think
which email client is it your favorite
comment that down below also drop a like
if you hope this trend leads to more
transparency and openness regarding
Google services and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggested video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions at
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one